and then we have kind of like the key  part the part that is making headlines  here where when the thighs are in  question Lewis she starts alleging that  her vagina has been touched in a way she  finds inappropriate let's continue  [Music]  all right so then the controversy  continues so I have mixed feelings about  this because as you know Lewis I find  these Pat Downs to be completely absurd  I don't go through the the um radiation  scanners I just don't want to deal with  it I get the pat down I don't care  they're feeling all over they're  sticking their hands inside my waistband  shaking it out airing it out you know  all the stuff tickling my armpits  telling me I should take it more  seriously all that stuff I just laugh it  off